you look healthy thank you i like to i
like to dress like i'm a
teacher's assistant at an ivy league
school
it's a good school though you look like
you got a lot of stress oh yeah yeah
it's brown but i'm
you know sailing through it
let's see i he said i look nice which i
appreciate you look nice but i don't
have a family you have like a family and
children you should look like a mess
i mean um
i it's hard now to go back and say yes
you do look nice now that i'm looking at
you
i mean what getting a closer look well
yeah i mean i saw you on the monitor and
i didn't quite like yeah is there do you
pay someone to
no i mean i i i think it's cool that
like your shirt has like was it like
like float owls what is that
yeah it kind of looks like the wallpaper
in a haunted mansion oh yeah
i'll call it an unneeded flourish
like a magician who keeps pulling
rabbits yeah i have to we get it
like that shirt would have been so much
better if there was one of those right
here
and then the jacket went over it
it's like
when i hung it up in the closet it had
one and then almost like every rabbit
started yeah exactly
wow the rabbits that was an expert call
back yeah you're well that's that's what
i do you merged it i emerged
you